[Müzik]
Evet sevgili Ankara Ankara'da olmak çok
güzel doğuma büyüme bütün okullarımı
burada okudum burada ilk hayatıma
başladım Onun için Ankara'da olmak
harika Özellikle de Ankara'da okuyup
çalışıp daha sonra İstanbul'a gidenlerde
falan budur daha yaygın bir şey Çünkü
buraya geldiğinizde bir yerden bir yere
gidebileceğinizi görüyorsunuz başka
şehirlerde pek mümkün olmuyor
şimdi tabi Ankara'nın tek güzelliği bu
değil mesela dürümcülere de çok güzel
bir hanımefendi daha önce dönerden falan
bahsetti şimdi buradaki pürüzlerden biri
de hangi dürümcüye Gideceğiniz konusu
olabilir hatta İstanbul'da şey esprisi
yapıyorlar Dürüm olmaz önce Ankara'da
millet ne yiyordu falan diye bir espri
şimdi bir sürü dürümcü var Birine gitmek
istiyorum ama hangisi Ne bileyim yazı
tura atmak bir yöntem olabilir Yazı Tura
atsam da şu yukarıdakine mi yoksa şu
soldakine mi gitsem dedim Yazı Tura
atacağım bir kelime oyunu yok hani yazı
tura atarken böyle işte para hileli mi
Yok efendim Tura tarafı daha ağır
attığınızda Tura tarafı yere gelir yazın
çıkma ihtimali falan bunları sallasak ve
desek ki hilesiz bir para atacağım bir
yazı çıkarsa Benim istediğim dürümceye
gideceğiz Tura çıkarsa sizinkine
gideceğiz ve ben yazı tura atmak
üzereyim yazı gelme ihtimalin nedir
Çok teşekkür ederim %50 Peki bu neye
bağlıdır efendim yani %50 ihtimalle yazı
gelmesi neye bağlı
genelde şans ama o şans denen şeyi
zorlayabiliriz şöyle zorlayabiliriz işte
ben dün buraya antrenmana geldim
sabahtan akşama kadar değil mi Yazı Tura
attım size söylediğiniz gibi defalarca
Attım elimi sabit tuttum paranın 4 kez
takla atmasını sağlamaya çalıştım yazıyı
üst tarafa koydum Rüzgar yoktu Işık
iyiydi falan bir süre sonra attığımı
vurabilirim yani defalarca atıp aslında
hep yazı gelmesini Belki de
sağlayabilirim yani bizim şu anda
%50'dir filan dediğin şey kuvvetle
muhtemeldir ki ölçemediğimiz için Yani
bütün parametreleri hakim olmadığımız
için Nahit bir şekilde atarsan %50 falan
diyorsunuz Oysa ben defalarca ölseydim
antrenman yapsaydım yüzlerce binlerce
kez işte efendim şu kadar Newton falan
toplamında tutturabilirdim bile şimdi bu
mesele Önemli çünkü hani böyle yazı
turada çok kritik olmayabilir ama mesela
Finans da önemli bir konu Yani paranızı
yönetsin diye işte paranızı insanlara
teslim ediyorsunuz portföy yönetim
şirketleri var değil mi fa yönetim
şirketleri falan bunları teslim
ettiğinizde sizin paranızı Valla büyük
ihtimalle kazandırırız falan diye
yönetseler sıkıntı çekerdik yani büyük
ihtimal diye bir şey yok orada durum
değişiyor Diyoruz ki işte biz
matematik kuracağız çok Optimum bir şey
yakalamaya çalışacağız Bununla ilgili
bir sürü Finans kitabı var bir bölümü
bizim ülkemizde kıymetli hocalarımızın
yazdığı kitaplar bir bölümü ise İşte
yurt dışında çeviri kitaplar ama
tamamında önemli birkaç konu vardır
portföy yönetimi ile ilgili şimdi
bunlardan bir tanesi mühim çalışmalardan
bir tanesini sizinle paylaşacağım Tabii
bir akşam olmuş altı buçuk böyle korkunç
bir grafik gelecek çok karışık anlamaz
çok zor ama hiç panik Yapmayın ben
buradayım size yardımcı olacağım Yani bu
çok zor grafiği hep beraber kolayca
okuyacağız yani
bu çok kırın çok zor grafik ki tepede
William
uzun süre yaptığı çalışmaların bir özeti
ve gördüğünüz gibi
risk getiri kardeştir diyor yani çok
kazanmak istiyorsanız fazla risk almanız
lazım Bir taraftan da diyor ki; yani
sizi çok Risk almaya Razı etmek için
size yüksek çok muazzam bir getiri
önermem sunmam lazım Bunun dışında Niye
o kadar yüksek risk alırsınız ki şimdi
bu Muazzam çalışma bugün vaktiniz de çok
da zor gibi gelmiyor Ben de bunu
biliyorum falan diyen arkadaşlara
mutlaka vardır bunun bir de ekürisi var
daha sonra çok daha daha ünlü olan bir
iktisatçı Finans'ın yaptığı bir çalışma
var O da diyor ki; ya şimdi bu arkadaşın
mevduat yerine parasını ne bileyim hisse
senedine yatırırsa çok daha fazla
kazanacağını biliyoruz ama
bir hisse yerine 5 hisseye yatırırsa
riski düşürebilir yani şu meşhur
çeşitlendirir portföy yap Böylece riskin
o kadar da yüksek olmasın meselesi
Harry marka gitse atfedilmiş ve 1990'da
Nobel ekonomi ödülü alıyor Bununla şimdi
bana ne söylüyor bunlardan bir tanesi
diyor ki Kardeşim bak işte risk getirin
kardeştir adabiyle riskal çok risk
alırsan çok kazanırsa falan öbürtü diyor
ki ya bir de bunu yaparken sen portreyi
oluştur bir tane bir şey ama üçe beşe
böl diyor
Oysaki Ankara'dayız türkiye'deyiz bir
sürü arkadaşım şöyle düşünüyor değil mi
bunları ben de biliyorum yani bunu ben
de yapardım Diyen arkadaşım bile Vardır
muhtemelen buna haber vermişler bunun
haber vermişler tabii böyle karikatürize
ettiğime bakmayın çok ciddi bir çalışma
Bu bugün bizi biliyoruz gibi gelebilir
buradaki pürüz şu; para yöneten Herkes
bu grafikleri biliyor bilmeyen arkadaşın
varsa artık siz de biliyorsunuz ama
sorun bunların içerisindeki o betalara
tetaları aldığınız hisseyi nereden
nereye koyacağınız büyük bir problem O
kolay bir iş değil İşte o kolay iş yani
grafiklerde kolay olan iş Çünkü
üniversitede bunu bir parametre olarak
veriyorlar Siz alıp çarpıyorsunuz
bölüyorsunuz Beta stetes tamam ama para
yönettiğinizde oradaki değişkenler Yok
onlar hayatın içinde işte o zaman
diyoruz ki; Histon bir problemimiz var
yani biz buradan böyle rahat gördük ama
bir problemimiz var Çünkü ben bunları
bulmakta zorlanıyorum
kullarda Bunu farklı şekillerde
öğretiyoruz işte karar ağaçları falan
var Finans kitaplarına baktığınızda
orada Diyoruz ki bak bir yatırım fırsatı
varsa şunları şunları yapacaksın mesela
bir yatırım fırsatımız var ve 1 milyon
lira para yatıracağız Buradaki herkesin
bir milyon lirası Vardır herhalde diye
düşünüyorum olmayan arkadaşlar sessizce
sağdan ve soldan
oturalım Şaka şaka şimdi
bir kutu var ve bu çıktıların
gerçekleşme olasılığı eşit yani deminki
%50 %50 ihtimalle bu ya da öbürü Peki
nedir bu çıktılar iyi ihtimal 4 milyon
lira kazanacağız yani 1 milyon lira
koyacağız 4 milyon kadın mı 3
kazanacağım Yani dediğim hani 1 milyon 4
milyon olacak ikinci ihtimal ise
yatırımımı sıfırlanacak Şimdi bunu
okulda Ben bir arkadaşlarıma genç
arkadaşlarıma anlatsam ya da bir hocamız
bana anlatsaydı şöyle ilerliyordu o
zaman bunun bir
dünyasını şöyle bir grafik üzerinde
gösterelim olasılık dağılımız nedir 0-50
ihtimalle 3 milyon lira kazanacağız
değil mi Hani bir koyuyoruz ya 3
kazanacağız 0.50 ihtimalle -1 milyon
paramızı kaybedeceğiz o zaman soğuk
matematik bana çok kolay bir cevap
veriyor 0.50 ihtimalle 3 milyon değil mi
0.50 ihtimalle -1 milyon Demek ki bu
yatırımı beklenen getirisi +1 milyon
lira bu yatırıma girilir diyoruz biz
süper okulda ve sınavda ve kitaplarda bu
çok basit
ya da var yok
sıfıra 50 %50 ihtimalle bunu kaybederim
yani matematik olarak doğru
kaybederseniz acaba çocuğun Okul taksiti
riske girer mi ya da o Bir Milyonu
kaybettiğinizde daha büyük bir şey
başınıza gelebilirmiş bunları
sormazsanız matematik olarak Bu gayet
sizi bulmuş şey
Bu arada Hani 050 ihtimalle bu 0 50
ihtimalle bu gerçek hayatta böyle bir
şey yok işe gireceğiz Baba ne olur 0-50
ihtimalle 4 milyon kazanırız bizim
dürümcüden falan böyle bir ihtimal yok
gerçek hayatta böyle bir şey yok
Dolayısıyla
bastı mı ilerlemiyor Saydım
gelecekte Risk Budur değil mi Risk nedir
şu anda hemen uygulamalı şeyini
yapıyoruz Risk Budur slaytımız
ilerlemiyor
risk gelecekte
istenmeyen bir durumun ortaya çıkma
ihtimali Peki bu istenmeyen durumun
ortaya çıktığı çıkma ihtimali şöyle bir
şey mi bugün yağmur yağabilir diye
şemsiye aldım yağmur yağarsa Şemsiyem
var
Şemsiyem yok ve yağmur yağarsa İşte bu
istenmeyen durum Peki Şemsiyen var ve
yağmur yağmazsa
sorun yok diyorsunuz da ben bütün iş
şemsiye taşımış oluyorum yani bu risk
tanımın içinde şöyle bir şey var bende
şemsiye var ya da yok ayrı konu yağmur
yağarsa başka bir şey ya Massa başka bir
şey olmalı Oysa burada durumu Şemsiyeye
bağladık Peki ya şöyle mi olmalıydı
Bugün şu saatlerde Ankara'da hava
sıcaklığı 22 derece olur diye tahmininde
bulundum
gömlek giydim 20 derece oldu bu bir risk
24 oldu Neyse canım Hava sıcak mı
diyeceğim yoksa ben hala tutturamadım mı
Ben hala tutturamadım Çünkü tahminim
20'ydi 18 tutturamadım 22 Yine
tutturamadım doğru tanım aslında
beklentiden sapmadır yani şemsiyeniz
olup olmaması değildir konu beklentiden
sapmadır şimdi burada bir diğer kavramda
belirsizlik çoğunlukla riskle aynı
anlamda kullanılıyor belirsizlik Oysaki
pratikte aynı şey değil belirsizliğin
benim açımdan en beğendiğim en basit
tanımlarından bir tanesi şu; elde
edilebilecek muhtemel sonuçların
dağılımı Bu işe girersek ne olabilir Şu
ya da şu iki ihtimal bu bu ya da bu üç
ihtimal belirsizlik yüksek şu 24
sonuçtan birisi olabilir derlerse
belirsizlik çok daha fazla yüksek oldu
Demek ki burada o dağılım ne kadar darsa
belirsizliği az diye yorumluyoruz Bak bu
da
iyi çözdü ama bu iki kavramla ilgili
minik birkaç tane sorum var Bunlardan
ilki şu
bu olumsuz sonucun ortaya çıkma ihtimali
yalnızca %10 olumsuz sonuç ne %10
ihtimalle öleceksiniz
%10 düşük bir ihtimalmiş şu anda artık
artık düşme ihtimali Dolayısıyla neyin
ihtimalden bahsettiğimize göre bu iş
değişir işsizlik tarihi düşük seviyede
%5 harika o işsiz bensem işsizlik yüzde
yüzdürmeye çok daha yüksek ya da
belirsizlik Aslında çok düşük Çünkü
sadece iki ihtimal var öyle mi nedir
Onlar ya batarız ya çıkarız doğru
belirsizlik gayet dar görünüyor Oysa Ki
bundan daha farklı bir şey Eğer siz o
işin içindeyseniz Dolayısıyla yine Hüsnü
yardıma çağırıyoruz
yani Düşünsene binlerce mühendis
çalışıyor milyarlarca dolar bağlamış
adamlar aya adam yolluyorlar şimdi
hesaplar var abi Tam çıkarken sürtün mü
olacak oradan meteor gelebilir göktaşı
çarpabilir Efendim oksijen bitebilir
falan Bu kadar çalışma var oradan biri
arıyor bir problemimiz var diye
Şu Karşı tarafta hüsnü'nden şöyle bir
cevap gelebilir Abi şu kadar operasyon
içinde bir tane problemin varsa boş ver
abi sana bir şey olmasın diyebilirler
yani gerçekten çok büyük bir
organizasyon Aslında şimdi Efendim bu
böyle risk belirsizlik falan
konuşulduğunda benim bir tane Hikayem
bir anım var o gelir aklıma farklı
eğitimlerde programlarda karşılaştığım
arkadaşların varsa bu adamın başka Anası
yok mu falan diyebilirler ama bu böyle
çok beğendiğim bir hikaye filan değil
Yaşadığım bir hikaye demin söyledim ben
Ankaralıyım burada doğduğum büyüdüm
eğitim okul üniversite falan ilk İşime
de ee Ankara'da başladım ve bir borsa
ile ilgili bir aracı kurumunda çalışmaya
başladım şimdi işe başladık çok gencim
benden bir 6-7 ay falan daha önce işe
başlamış benden bir yaş küçük genç bir
arkadaş var onunla beraber işe başladık
benden önce gelmiş ya askerdeki kıdem
gibi böyle soruyorum Abi bu nereden
ekranlardan kapı nereden alarm nereden
falan çok çalışkan bir çocuk işletme
Okumuş Bir taraftan da II uluslararası
ilişkiler Master yapıyor Çok da Çalışkan
sürekli işte Bilgisayar bozuluyor teknik
servis arayacağız Ee bu diyor ki ya
Nasılsa teknik servis gelecek bir ben
kurcalasam bilgisayarı Belki tamir
ederim ya edemezsem Nusret teknik servis
gelecek bak diyoruz
işte diyorlar ki mesela haftada böyle 4
gün tatil olur hani cumayı kaytarsanız 9
gün tatil yaparsınız ya
herkes gider müdürüm ben kaçsam Cuma
günü diye o gelip diyor ki Cuma Ben
çalışabilir miyim Biz diyoruz ki yani
böyle bir ekip arkadaşımız olduğu için
çok mutluyuz Bu adam çalışıyor Biz
tatile gidiyoruz falan diyorum ki oğlum
sen niye kalıyorsun Cuma herkes tatile
gidecek ya diyor Müşteri falan da gelmez
bilmediğin ekranlara falan çalışırım çok
güzel olur diyor işte Eskiden Şimdiki
gibi cep telefonunuzdan Çat diye hisse
alamıyorsunuz fiyatlar uydudan çanak
antenden geliyor Ankara'da şimdiki
Ankara değil kar başlamışlar her tarafta
kar var çanak anteninin içine Kar
yağdığında veri gelmez yani Kar yağıyor
Sen fiyatları göremiyorsun apartman
görevlisini arıyoruz abi çıkıver de
çanağı temizle falan diye Bu diyor ki
abi ben çıkabilir miyim
Oğlum sen niye çıkıyorsun çatıya diyor
ki abi kar nereye gelince ekran
bozuluyor görmek istiyorum çık oğlum
Allah seni bildiği gibi yapsın Falan
diyoruz
dayıları var mesela Bir gün gelmiş iki
dil biliyoruz 3 dil öğreneceğim ben
ücretsiz bir kurs buldum italyanca'ya mı
Japonca'ya mı gideyim dedi Dedim ki 3
dili oğlum lazım değilsen bunlarla falan
abi Nasılsa gideceğim hangisine gideyim
dedi O zamanlar Ankara'da Japonca
öğrenebileceğiniz bir yer yok hani dedim
Japonca bir fırsat bari Japonca öğren
onu da yaptık geldi Hadi son bir şey
daha söyleyeyim çankaya'dayız Kızılay'da
şubeler açılacak ustalarla kabloları
falan çekiyor Müdür dedi ki Oğlum bir
yere gitsin bunların başında Dursun Hani
kaplamam da geçiyor doğru yerden mi
geçiyor çalışmaya gideceğiz biz lacivert
takım elbiseyi işimizin başındayız yani
ne gideceksin ustaların başına buyuruyor
ki ben giderim abi hadi oğlum sen git
falan biz çok mutluyuz
ikimiz diyorum ya En çömeziz akşamları
da o zamanlar yine internet falan yok
faks genç arkadaşlara bilir mi fax diye
bir cihaz var
faks gelecek borsadan teyitleşeceğiz ben
de onu Beklerken İngiliz bir dergi var
Ekonomi Dergisi çok meşhur hala var olan
ondan böyle Haberlere bakıyorum baktım
bir iş ilanı dedim ki birader gel Seni
arıyorlar nasıl abi dedi dedim bak Seni
arıyorlar
Uluslararası bir Amerikan yatırım
bankası Asya pasifik'te açacağı yeni
şubesi için İngilizce bilen tercihen
bölge dillerinden birini bilen yeni şube
açma tecrübesi olan
enflasyonist ülke vatandaşı ya da böyle
bir piyasada 2 yıl çalışmış olan eleman
aramaktadır Oğlum diyorum Seni arıyorlar
dedi ki abi bu uluslararası baskı dünya
baskısı yani binlerce adam vardır dedim
bu kadar saçma özelliği bir arada olan
kişi vardır dünyada bunun 950 tanesinin
çok iyi bir işi vardır kalan 50 tane 40
tanesi bu dergiyi okumaz
o kalan 10 kişinin 5 tanesi kesin beni
almazlar diye başvurmaz sen dedim
girebilirsin başvurdu arka tarafa sonra
öğreniyoruz adama beğenmişler
çağıracaklar mülakata fakat oradaki
Amerikan kurumunun Türkiye'deki muhabiri
de bizim çalıştığımız kurum adamlar
diyor ki bunların elemanını çalarsak
Hani ayıp olur mu diye bizi İnsan
kaynaklarını arıyorlar diyorlar ki
sizden çok sevdik Alacağız da sizi ayıp
olmasın Hani bu çocuğu alabilir miyiz
onlar da diyor ki 2 dakika dur Ankara'yı
bizi arıyorlar Oğlum bizde böyle genç
pırlanta gibi çocuk varmış yan masada
oturuyor ya niye yok da şube açacağız
böyle biri lazımdı bunu gönderelim
dediler
Bizim şirketteki en Çömez adam New York
şubesini açmaya gitti 30 yıldır
Amerika'da çalışıyor
şimdi bu olaya hazırlık yapmanız mümkün
mü
mümkün değil bunun hazırlık yapamazsınız
bu hayatı hazır Olmaktır böyle
belirsizlik var Ben bununla ilgili
çalışıp Bir de Japonca öğrenmem lazım
diye bir
planınız Muhtemelen olamaz buradaki
hikaye buna çalışmak mümkün değil buna
Bu anlamda hazır olmak mümkün yani o şey
olacak diye değil ama ben burada
çalışırım Ben bunu yaptıktan sonra o
fırsat çıkarsa bunu yaparım o Fırsat
çıkar ve ben hazır değilsem İşte o zaman
Histon bir problemimiz var
[Alkış]
[Müzik]